One day my boyfriend asked me:
Hey, if you could travel in time and choose your own period. where would you go
and I laughed and said:
Nowhere. this is the best time to be an asian woman.
Dur!
He looked very surprised for a moment before he realized.
Oh.
because of this i started to think of a saying that very much
our cultural consciousness has been going around lately.
"check your privilege"
so actually says "check your privilege"
Yo. when you consider someone else's condition
then be aware of the specific privileges in which you were born
so that you can put them aside and accurately try to understand
how someone else's situation might be.
so when my boyfriend said:
I never thought about it that way
I started to wonder: what is my privilege?
and I do have a few. I mean. i was born in a family
who placed a lot of value in study
okay darling, i'll give you a cent for every page.
because I am stingy as f * ck, I had a lot of incentive to study.
your daughters is the first in our primary school that
has read the entire section of the young adult library.
money money money.
my father was in the army.
so I was exposed to many different cultures and countries.
and people. this has given me a number of dialects
who are very embarrassing now.
when i was a kid. I lived in North Carolina
* speaks Japanese *
okay bruh we hunted that motha fucka to the parking lot.
oh em gee. are you bitches to talking about sush sush?
we really have to go to the Suga Fish. (restaurant) it's great.
and after puberty, I started to be seen as cute.
often beautiful. which I walked a lot on the way
now as you can see i have this graph. the prettier you are
the more cats your potential partner will allow.
in the end I hope that by having this thought it makes me a better person.
and that I can sympathize more with other people and their problems.
like not everyone is born with parents see still being together.
and can stand behind their dreams. or that she lived in a normal family
or in which they were taught to start working very young.
or experienced the world and were exposed to different things.
it's so easy to look at someone through your own little lens
and write off the things they have trouble with.
or say that someone's problem is simply used as an excuse or complaint.
it's a lot harder to keep your own opportunities in mind.
only because of the place where you were born.
I am certainly guilty of doing that.
altogether. we are moving in the direction of empathy.
and I think that's great.
which reminds me. I asked my boyfriend:
if you could travel time to any period in time where would you go?
the 1960's
Cool.
I have no idea where Asian people were in the 60s
I'm not sure either
where were we?
I'm Anna Akane. stay great Gotham.
a thank you to Audible for sponsoring this episode.
Audible.com is the leading provider of audio books.
with more than 180,000 downloadable titles from which you can choose.
i love to listen to audio books when traveling through the mountains and adventures.
or just to fold my dirty laundry that just takes a lot of time.
I am currently listening to Stephen King's "insomnia"
because I love all the spooky stories he writes.
you can choose that or another book of your choice.
at audible.com/anna.
that's audible.com/anna
* poof *